now that we've done a series of videos
and on america's interventions during
the cold war in korea
korea and cuba
and vietnam i thought it would be fun
just to think a little bit about whether
there are any patterns here and once
again in all of these history videos you
have to take anything i say or really
anything anyone says about history with
the grain of salt even when it comes to
the facts obviously the facts can only
be written by the people who survive who
knows what might have gone on behind
scenes that never got documented by the
historians so you have to take
everything with the grain of salt and
even when you know in this video i'll
talk about maybe some patterns or some
themes that i've seen don't take that as
just the truth think about it for
yourself if it makes sense it makes
sense if it doesn't
try to look into it more and try to come
up with your own themes or your patterns
or things that you can learn from so the
general pattern across all of these is
that before the u.s got involved and
before a kind of a a communist leaning
regime got involved these were all in
some ways subjugated populations in
korea
it was subjugated by
the japanese it was a japanese colony in
cuba it was subjugated by the batista
government
and this was a dictatorship a corrupt
dictatorship and it was heavily
influenced by the united states you
could almost view it as united states
influence they had some a united states
colony they had so much influence with
batista and in the case of vietnam it
was a french colony so you can imagine
in all of these situations the existing
rulers were not that popular people were
looking for rulers who could kind of
liberate them from from the messes they
were inside of that on top of that and
this comes to the whole discussion of
capitalism versus communism you can
imagine that when you are colonized or
when you are in a corrupt regime you do
have people accruing wealth
so there are people accruing wealth some
of whom who get it without without being
kind of that legitimate and so these
circles are kind of the size of
different people's wealth so you can
imagine in korea under under japanese
rule maybe there were a few people who
were successful by being legitimate
entrepreneurs but there were probably a
whole bunch of people who were
successful by just kind of sucking up to
the colonial powers in the case of a
corrupt regime
doing things that were corrupt with the
regime using the regime to get undue
power in a certain market and it's
always a combination in any in any of
these countries there were probably some
entrepreneurs and some other people who
got wealth maybe with good means and
then some other people who under these
regimes got wealth with
under questionable means maybe because
they sucked up to the corrupt regime or
maybe they even just did outright
criminal activity which was probably the
case in the batista regime you probably
did have people who were just outright
criminals doing very well for themselves
same thing in vietnam the maybe the
vietnamese some of the vietnamese who
really kind of were aligned with the
french probably got extra favors and so
their wealth wasn't necessarily due to
innovation or competence but really just
where they fit into the political order
maybe some other people did have did
have legitimate wealth so you imagine
when any of these type of situations
start to emerge from subjugation so you
start having independence movements
in all of these
in all of these situations you could
imagine it's a very popular notion to
run on
and depending on how true it is but it's
a very popular notion to run on to tell
people look you've seen all of these
people who've gotten questionable wealth
and maybe some of these people who got
questionable wealth got it by being
aligned with our subjugators by being to
some degree traitors to our people and
once again maybe not all the people but
you can see how it's a popular line for
someone coming to power when you're
emerging from independent or emerging
into independence to say why don't we
redistribute wealth
why don't we take the wealth from this
person right here who got it in
questionable means and redistribute it
and redistribute it to the rest of the
society why don't we take it from this
person over here and redistribute it to
the rest of society why don't we do that
with this person here and redistribute
that wealth to the rest of society and
if you're looking for a a political
ideology that seems to fit with this
idea of of trying to correct things that
maybe looked wrong during the colonial
or the subjugated rule communism seems
to fit that it's kind of a
redistribution redistributing of wealth
or maybe the state takes over all wealth
or or maybe something in between where
it's socialist where the state is
redistributing wealth fairly
aggressively but you still have kind of
un the underpinnings of capitalism and
so you can imagine that communism
especially to a population that
where you have many many many poor
people
well concentrated in a few people many
of them who are aligned with the old
regimes communism at least seems like a
popular notion and you have people who
ride this nationalistic communistic
feeling in the case of cuba you have
people like fidel castro
people like fidel castro in in vietnam
you have people like ho chi minh
ho chi minh and then korea is a little
bit different because you did have a
communist nationalist independence
movement
but kim il-sung
wasn't necessarily the leader of that
movement that the soviets actually
didn't want any of those people in
charge any of the the kind of the
nationalist communists the leaders of
those movement they kind of marginalized
them and installed kimball's song
probably because he was more aligned
with them but he was communist
kim
il-sung now the reality is these guys
come in under these very egalitarian you
know equality for all let's get
retribution for the wrongs that were
done to us before but probably all of
them start to not just redistribute
wealth from people who might have gotten
it in bad ways but they're also just
redistributing wealth generally maybe
because it's just a popular thing to do
or maybe because these people didn't
give them proper support so they're
getting retribution on their political
enemies as opposed to as opposed to just
kind of doing it for for social good so
you know they might do it from people
who have legitimate wealth and so those
people aren't too happy about it and
they ride this kind of communist
egalitarian movement to install
themselves and instead of just being a
purely marxist state they kind of want
to be more marxist leninist where you
have this communist party that has this
continuous revolution which is a
justification
for them to never hold real elections
and always stay in power so by no means
is this kind of a rationale why these
people are legitimate but what happened
in every one of these cases is that the
united states was in the middle of the
cold war they feared the spread of
communism communism tended to correlate
with a non-free state it doesn't have to
be that way but every time communism was
implemented it also was this kind of
authoritarian rule no democracy and you
could also imagine there were many
capitalists in the united states who for
their own selfish reasons were afraid of
capitalism spreading to the united
states because maybe their wealth would
be distribute redistributed but
regardless of what the justification
whether it was a more noble wanting
people to have freedom of of expression
freedom of freedom to own property or
whether it was more selfish that hey we
don't want our own wealth to be somehow
taken away or it was just might have
been a balance of power between the u.s
and the soviet union that every time a
communist a country fell to communism
it's somehow the u.s losing
some power in the world
regardless of the us's rationale they
always say okay
these guys are communists we're going to
take the other side of the equation so
the u.s ends up supporting the us ends
up supporting sigmund re
sigmundry
in
south korea who we know was not the best
character in the world they end up
supporting dm
they end up supporting dm in south
vietnam who we also know was not the uh
necessarily the most savory person in
the world in the case of cuba the us at
least they did support batista while he
was in power but we saw in that video
that kennedy later came on says you know
batista was a pretty bad dude and it was
probably a big mistake for the u.s to
support him but the u.s goes on the
other side and they support the exiles
against fidel castro and here the cuban
exiles
they're not
i wouldn't they're they're definitely
not in the category of sigmund re or dm
and they probably favor democracy and
overall good people but what they
probably did feed kennedy is a story
that fidel castro wasn't as popular as
he actually was and he probably was more
popular especially after the revolution
because he had this egalitarian people
were getting over batista kind of
anybody but batista they would be happy
about fidel castro was this charismatic
leader who was kind of working for the
poor at least it looked like he was
working for the poor so at least in the
in the get-go uh
the the the especially the kennedy
administration might have been fed an
overly optimistic view that kind of got
them involved in the bay of pigs
invasion and all of that but this is
just the general pattern that happened
every time and every time it ended up in
either a u.s defeat or a stalemate and
it you know take whatever lessons there
are from this but it is a kind of an
interesting pattern that had happened
multiple times pretty much every
engagement that we had during the cold
war